[Music]
nice llama welcome to la carne I'm going
to show you all of my Coachella wardrobe
personally I love festivals just because
I like the freedom with the fashion like
there are no boundaries you can wear
what you want you could do your makeup
however you want and no not that you can
obviously when you're at home I just
feel like everyone so much more like
happy and free-spirited at festivals and
you know 80 people would like space gems
and glitter everywhere it's just a real
like fun than atmosphere and event to
the earth so this year I'm at Coachella
with very exclusive you have some
amazing brands I've been abandoned by
very exclusive for so long and they're
obviously dressing me or cachoeira so I
thought I'd give it a look this is my
Coachella day one outfit this is a dress
and keepsake I absolutely love the
flared sleep I also have this which is
the most adorable off the shoulder like
frill top now sometimes it can get a
little bit chilly in LA and impulse
rings in the evening so I've also got
that covered
I've got this insane McCue denim jacket
what I love about this is all the
different colors of denim so there are
some other things I'm going to hang at
Coachella obviously I've got a low shoes
and a load of accessories I'm also going
to show you right let's talk accessories
probably like one of my favorite things
about vegetables because you can just go
so over the top and maybe know things
that you wouldn't normally do in life
Doceri
life and your life back at home what is
a festival without a bandana this hat I
think is formally misguided now I'm a
lack of sunglasses hoarder I probably
got like 30 pairs at home so choosing
which one that made the cup of dark
Verger outfits was quite tough but I've
got two pairs of ray-bans these like my
ultimate favorites I've got some paint
glasses just really fun I mean I'm not
sure how happens they're going to be
actually blocking out any Sun but I
think they looked really cool these
aren't any glasses right
absolutely adore and I think they're so
cute and kind of retro so I'd definitely
be rocking these in the desert after
that obviously I need a bag because I
need to be able to get my phone and a
camera in there and a lip balm and
Auntie back Jill that's always a must at
first of all if I have a bad back gel
I'm not going so all my bags have to be
like proof that they could like fit or
load in and these are ones that pass the
test these two bags are from coach and I
have obsessed with this or half festival
with it with all the studs and all that
the colors like leaves like it's just so
not another studied one can coach
slightly smaller this is a bit more
muted ones than the than this one's got
a lot going on and then this which is a
recently newly purchased by little last
class bag again with logos and I really
really like the chain as well so as well
at all of that stuff I've already got a
bit more as well these are just seeing
that pretty much any time I go away I
always take with me first off again in
short because I just feel like can't go
roll the dinner short and if you can't
me what to wear
Chuck on the denim shorts this adorable
top it looks tiny but I've because it's
a defecated so when I could have under
stretch it out a little bit this again
I'm off the shoulders top I think this
is from River Island and actually this
pairs of these q v-neck cup like
oversized band t-shirt flash dress so
you could kind of wear it as either you
could wear this with trainers if you're
casually out in the back in the day or
go to work with a heel kind of plan it
up a little bit and then after all of
that obviously I have to get my exercise
in and especially after Coachella and
even up bit of R&R take care of my body
so I've obviously had to bring with some
workout where I've got these Reebok
leggings which are pretty much live in
all
and if their sports bra also Reebok
there's a nice bit of the pending human
here as well so that's not be wearing
post-katrina and I'm trying to look
after my body and apologize for all the
late nights and crazy dancing output and
it's very well some of the first of all
I'm really looking forward to tell her
this weekend I did go - the end of my
third time so I feel like this year I
kind of know what to expect but I feel
so like the unexpected or what happens
at movie festival anyway I hope you've
enjoyed I got a little insight into my
life pre-katrina pret I armies actually
get ready for a trailer so it's time to
you live for more videos like this don't
forget
[Music]